notre dame de chartres l'immaculée sali
par le temps et la pollution pour la
nettoyer
rien de mieux que du vin comme celui de
tami anjard madame blanc aussi ce
viticulteur participe pour la première
fois à la peau les chartraines vendre sa
production de riz celle appelée aussi en
offrir jean van hamme
vous faites don de 6 bouteilles de pinot
gris de relier ces bouteilles seront
vendus aux enchères en octobre un don
pour restaurer les vitraux de la
cathédrale
si ça peut aider à améliorer notre
patrimoine français notamment achats
ça n'avait plus que bénéfique et nous ça
nous touche vraiment de faire ce nom là
derrière cette récolte une association
locale toute la journée
recueillir les 20 des 40 vignerons
présents et des particuliers très belle
bouteille en fait de saint-émilion grand
cru qui sera ensuite dédicacé par le
chef cuisinier thierry marx parrain de
cette cuvée 2018 une opération bien
huilé l'espoir de récolter 80 mille
euros sachant qu'une qu'une baie
restauré en fait ça coûte 150 mille
euros l'idée c'est d'avoir un maximum de
bouteilles pour avoir une très belle
vente on appelle aussi les entreprises à
faire du mécénat du crowdfunding pour
l'association restaurer la cathédrale
rime avec patience en trois ans de levée
de fonds et de mécénat
elle a réuni cent cinquante mille euros
l'état s'est engagé à hauteur de cent
cinquante mille euros également une
somme dédiée à la restauration de ces
vitraux éviteront qui ont été restaurées
dans les parties hautes ont été doublés
vous voyez le vert de noble âge d'ici
alors que les ce les vitraux des parties
basses n'ont pas n'ont pas ce vers de
nouvelles âge parce qu'ils ont été
restaurés antérieurement et là
aujourd'hui la campagne pour laquelle
nous sommes présents aujourd'hui sur
marché de la police et pour restaurer
les vitraux du transept nord
après le vin aux enchères opération
start up en octobre l'association
rencontrera deux jeunes entrepreneurs
pour lever de nouveaux fonds